Über 1000 Spieler, die Wetten abgeschlossen haben. 100 von ihnen wurden nun gesperrt. Der Liga-Betrieb in der zweiten und der dritten Liga, der ist gerade ausgesetzt. Acht Haftbefehle wurden erlassen gegen Schiedsrichter und den Präsidenten des Erstligisten, Elyip Spor. Ihr habt vielleicht vom Wett-Skandal in der Superliga und der Türkei mitbekommen. Wir wollen jetzt darüber sprechen, hier im Rasenfunk, mit Gökhan Yagmur von transfermarkt.de. Und jetzt geht's los. Das erstes Publikum, der Rasenfunk.
Nach 25 Jahren als Trainer und 35 Jahren als Fußballer, habe ich noch nie etwas ähnliches gesehen. Es hat eine Dimension, die über alles geht, was unterstehbar ist. Und ich denke nicht, dass ein Club, ein einziger Club, ein System zerstören wird.
Ja, also gebe ich dir recht, definitiv. Es geht ja los mit dem Präsidenten des Schiedsrichterverbandes, der eben auch ein Konto hat, ein Wettkonto.
Das ist doch unfassbar.
Wo er dann gesagt hat, da muss ich ein bisschen lachen, wo er dann gesagt hat, ja, ich habe dieses Wettkonto, aber das habe ich nie. Ich habe nie drüber gespielt. Ich habe den nur zur Beobachtung der Spiele oder der Mannschaften. Keine Ahnung. Da habe ich geguckt, mit großem Auge, habe gesagt, what?
Es gibt ja keine anderen Apps, mit denen man Spiele beobachten kann. Ich verstehe es total.
Du hast auch ein Flash-Score, wo du das ebenfalls machst. Du musst schon ein Wertkonto. Das ist klar. Wie gesagt, da war für mich auch klar, da stimmt auch irgendwas nicht. Fakt ist, ich sage es nochmal ganz klar, für mich ist in den unteren Ligen wird ganz klar gehandelt. Ganz klar, von allen Seiten. Schiedsrichter, vielleicht wurden sie auch angewiesen, also jetzt nicht, dass der Schiedsrichter selber draufkommt und sagt, ich mache das jetzt, sondern der wird vom Verband irgendwie darauf angewiesen. Keine Ahnung, das kann ich mir alles gut vorstellen. Spieler und so weiter. Da wirkt die Mafia groß, bin ich mir ziemlich sicher. So wie man eben, und da gehe ich auch, ich glaube nicht, dass man einfach mal so die Ugandische Liga tippen kann. Ich glaube auch dort, also ist ja nicht von Interesse, aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, wenn, egal wo, mafiatechnisch ziemlich groß was drin ist und du das wetten kannst, dass diese Spiele manipuliert sind. Und das kannst du eben mit Uganda machen, das kannst du machen mit, was weiß ich, Singapur oder so. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, welche Ligen da klein genug sind, damit man das machen kann und eben die unteren Ligen der Türkei. Und da bin ich mir ganz sicher, dass dort alles geht. Ich glaube, also sind wir ganz lüchtern betrachtet. Wir wissen seit Corona, dass Fußball nicht nur ein Sportart ist, sondern systemrelevante Ereignisse. Das alles über überdauern kann, dass dort die Staatsanwaltschaft nicht einfach hingeht und sagt, so jetzt aus Verdacht machen wir das jetzt ganz vorsichtig. Da muss man ganz vorsichtig sein. Und wenn man in einem ganz vorsichtigen Thema so sich weit nach vorne lehnt, dann ist da nicht zu 100, sondern zu 1000 Prozent was dran. Die Frage ist eben nur, in welchem Maße. Und deswegen haben sie geguckt, mal gucken, wie weit das geht, wie weit wir das spreaden können. Und es ging tatsächlich eben so weit, dass es ein bisschen in die Super League geht, auch wenn das eben Spieler sind. Und deswegen sieht man ja auch, dass das eben nur türkische Spieler sind und eben keine ausländischen. Dass das eben Leute sind, die aus von unten kommen, sag ich mal, aus den Amateurbereichen nach oben und die dann eben selber dort auch schon gespielt haben. Und das ist eigentlich auch der Beweis eigentlich für mich.
Ja, aber das sind ja die Spieler, das verstehe ich auch alles. Aber wie groß, glaubst du, ist jetzt das Problem bei den Schiedsrichtern? Weil wenn es gegen 17 einen Haftbefehl gibt. Ich habe jetzt aber ehrlicherweise nicht mehr genau nachgeguckt. Da sind jetzt auch wenige, die in der obersten Liga pfeifen mit drin. Aber trotzdem, das ist ja insofern auch ein Problem, weil du brauchst ja auch Schiedsrichter, gute Schiedsrichter, um Wettbewerb aufrechtzuerhalten.
Das ist jetzt werden hier viele Schiedsrichter aus dem Verkehr gezogen. Zu Recht auch. Zumindest das, was ich weiß. Ich möchte hier niemanden irgendwie was Böses. Jetzt hast du also der Präsident, der Verbandspräsident meinte auch letztens keine Angst, wir haben noch genug Schiedsrichter, um die Liga so weiterzuführen.
Na super.
Genau. Aber das heißt ja eben, genau, wenn da jetzt, weiß ich nicht, über 100 Schiedsrichter wegfallen jetzt, dann hast du schon ein Problem für die Zukunft. So schnell kriegst du eben keine. Gerade nicht in dem Land, wo es überhaupt nicht erstrebenswert ist, für Kinder und Jugendliche zu sehen, ah ja, ich werde Schiedsrichter, das ist richtig cool. Nee, eben nicht. Und das sehen sie. So, und so hast du dir jetzt ein extremes Nadelöhr geschaffen. Na ja, was heißt, es klingt jetzt so, als ob ich die Schuld beim Link suche, beim Präsidenten. Das ist es ja nicht. Es ist ja wie es ist. Und deswegen, da werden jetzt natürlich, es geht immer um die unteren Bereiche, da kann ich mir vorstellen, zweierlei. Erstmal, wie gesagt, vom Verband, weil der ist genauso verdächtig, der Schiedsrichterverband, dass da von oben was kam, mach das, mach dies. Mach jenes. Oder eben, die Mafia direkt zu den Schiedsrichtern kommen und sagen, du kriegst so und so, mach es. Und das Geld ist einfach attraktiver als die Gehälter, die sie dort bekommen. Das ist auch Fakt. Deswegen funktioniert es ja da unten. Es funktioniert da unten und eben nicht, ich weiß gar nicht jetzt, ich müsste lügen, ich weiß nicht, was ein Schiedsrichter in der Super League verdient, ehrlich gesagt. Aber davon kannst du schon gut leben. So und eben in der dritten oder vierten Liga eben nicht. Und dann, jetzt kommt die Charakterfrage eben. Weil dann frag ich mich zum Beispiel, okay, warum ist das in anderen Ländern nicht so? Und da ist eben so und jetzt werden vielleicht einige Türken dann auch sagen, wie redet er eigentlich über die Türkei? Aber leider so ist es so. Wir sind oder nicht wir, die Türken sind einfach Geldgeier, bierig. Das Geld ist alles in der Türkei. Es geht alles über das Geld. Wenn du Geld hast, was du machst und Werte wie, ja, Standhaftigkeit, Disziplin, Gutherzigkeit und keine Ahnung was. Also gutherzig sind sie schon teilweise natürlich. Aber so Disziplin, Standhaftigkeit und so weiter, die fallen sehr weit runter. Das hat auch Bedingt, jetzt kann ich jetzt politisch übergehen mit der Inflation des Landes und so weiter und so fort. Die Leute wissen nicht, wie sie über den Tag kommen. All das spielt rein in die Hand der Wettmafia. Ganz klar. Die dann sagen, die dann direkt zum Schiedsrichter gehen und sagen als Beispiel, so und so, kriegst du das und das, machst du bitte das. Dann wiegt dir das ab, ich kriege das für dieses Spiel oder ich kriege das, wenn ich das mache. Da ist das für viele dann keine Frage mehr.
Und wenn du das das erste Mal gemacht hast, kommt die Mafia und sagt, wenn du nicht das nächste Mal wieder machst, dann sagen wir, was du beim ersten Mal gemacht hast.
Dann bist du drin. Einmal gemacht, bist du drin. Und wie gesagt, für mich ist auch der Präsident, der der der der der Schiedsrichter-Komitee höchst suspekt. Ich kann ihm nichts beweisen. Ich habe auch jetzt auch staatsanwaltschaftlich konnte jetzt mal nichts bewiesen werden, nur dass er dieses Wettkonto hat. Dass er für Recherche braucht. Keine Ahnung.
Ja, und es sind einfach komische Sachen passiert. Also wir hatten es ja schon im Frühjahr 2022, dass im laufenden Spielbetrieb 13 Schiedsrichter, die bis dahin in der Super League gepfiffen haben, bis zum Saisonende suspendiert wurden. Und so richtig weiß man bis heute nicht, warum eigentlich.
Ja, genau. Und das ist, es passieren, wie du schon sagst, komische Sachen. Es gibt noch einen Fall, der ist jetzt so ein bisschen ab, gehört aber auch zum Schiedsrichterwesen. Es gab eine Geschichte von einer Schiedsrichterfrau, diesen Namen ich jetzt leider vergessen habe. Sie ist jetzt mittlerweile, ist sie Social Media Phänomen oder wie sich das nennt, keine Ahnung. Und die hatte immer auch gute Spiele bekommen, auch im Amateurbereich trotzdem. Kam dann im Endeffekt raus, dass sie ein Verhältnis zu dem Schiedsrichter Obmann hatte, die für sie zuständig war. Warum ich das erzähle, ist einfach das Ding, dass Schiedsrichterwesen gleichzusetzen mit Seriosität, Fairness, OSW und noch ein paar andere Attribute. Und das ist in der Türkei durch diese Geschichten, die man immer wieder hört, auch durch komische Geschichten, die du gerade erwähnt hast, warum passiert so was, ohne dass man es weiß, passt einfach gut zusammen, wo man dann sagt, ja, okay, hier stimmt was nicht. Generell bin ich bei den Schiedsrichtern, wenn es in der Super League angeht oder auch in der zweiten Liga, halte ich die für sauber. Nicht super ausgebildet, aber für sauber. So. Aber da unter, eben wie gesagt, weil der Fokus nicht da drauf ist, für sehr schmutzig. Und das ist halt so das Ding, dass dieses Schiedsrichterwesen, nicht im Allgemeinen, aber sehr viele Leute und auch Leute, die in gewissen Positionen sind, einfach Dreck am Stecken haben und dass sich dann wie so ein, ja, wie so, wie so Äste sich dann praktisch durch die ganzen Ligen und Verbände durchzieht.
Ja, Menschen sind sich ja gleich, das ist egal, woher du kommst, aber die Strukturen sind ebenso unterschiedlich. Und da hast du ja sehr viele Dinge jetzt genannt. Also ich glaube nicht, dass sich der Charakter da so groß unterscheidet, von Menschen, aber wenn du eben in einem gewissen, in einer Umgebung aufwächst, dann prägt das das sein. Da kann man ja ganz philosophisch werden.
Ich möchte dir ganz höflich widersprechen. Also ich bin hier in Deutschland geboren, aufgewachsen, bin Deutscher und bin auch Türkei und ich kenne beide, ja wie soll ich sagen, beide kulturell sehr gut. Und ich sehe beim Deutschen eine Disziplin, die da ist und auch ein Ehrgefühl, die dann durchgezogen wird. Ich rede nicht generell, ich rede generell und nicht in Einzelfälle. Natürlich gibt es Einzelfälle, die dann auch scheiße sind, keine Frage. Und in der Türkei, das sind keine schlechteren Menschen per se, aber durch diese, was dort alles passiert, durch die Situation, sind sie dann irgendwann, ich glaube jeder Mensch wird dann auch irgendwann denken, okay, das, das, das.
Ja, das meine ich ja, die Umgebung, die formt dich.
Genau, die Umgebung. Ja, also mit Strukturen dachte ich, du meinst hier so innerhalb der TFF oder innerhalb der...
Ach so, nein, nein, ich meinte, ich meinte es ganz allgemein.
Ja, okay, sorry, da hast du natürlich recht.
Ja, richtig. Ich wollte bloß diese vermeidliche Pauschalisierung ein bisschen einordnen und erklären, weil ich versuche immer Klischees zu vermeiden, ehrlich gesagt passt mir das auch nicht so ganz, dass das jetzt auch der türkische Fußball da wieder diesem Klischee so erlegt. Und deswegen bin ich froh, dass wir jetzt aber zum Beispiel schon mal die Spielerseite so aufklären konnten. Was aber so ein bisschen dann für mich so die Frage ist, wenn man jetzt dann nach vorne blickt. Also bei den Spielern scheint es mir so zu sein, dass das gut aufgearbeitet werden kann und dass es vor allem gar nicht so sehr in den Profibereich rein ragt. Bei den Schiedsrichtern und Schiedsrichterinnen, da haben wir jetzt aber noch mal ein anderes Thema. Wie glaubst du denn, geht es jetzt weiter? Und was muss deiner Meinung nach passieren, um jetzt dann, hier sprechen wir jetzt dann doch über die Strukturen im TFF, um da die Strukturen zu schaffen, dass man Schiedsrichterei attraktiv halten kann und trotzdem aber auch in einem Rahmen, der der Liga angemessen ist und der Begeisterung für die Liga angemessen ist. Weil das scheint ja aktuell nicht so zu sein.
Das ist eine sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr schwierige Frage. Denn wie willst du in einem Land, wo Leute sehen, wo jeder sehen kann, wie Schiedsrichter behandelt werden und die selber sie auch so behandeln, wie willst du Leute, wie willst du Jugendliche und Kinder dafür motivieren? Wie willst du, wenn immer wieder solche Geschichten rauskommen, sie dazu motivieren, neutral zu sein, fair zu sein? Dieses Fair Play wird in Türkei im Moment gar nicht geschrieben. Also es ist nicht sichtbar, sage ich jetzt mal so. Bei jeder Fehl-Pfiff-Aktion oder bei jeder Aktion, wo man denkt, wird sofort Manipulation gerufen, wird sofort Skandal gerufen, wird sofort irgendwas, weil die Leute einfach nicht mehr dran glauben. Die glauben einfach nicht mehr an die Fairness des türkischen Fußballs. Da ist so viel kaputt gegangen. Jeder, der jetzt Schiedsrichter werden möchte oder wird, wird es schwierig haben. Ist einfach wie es ist. Wir hatten einmal Glück mit Cenk Cakir, einen wunderbaren Schiedsrichter zu haben, den ich wirklich gefeiert habe ohne Ende, der auch richtig gut war. Und trotzdem, selbst der wurde fertig gemacht in Türkei, wo ich wirkliches Verständnis einfach verliere. Sein Sohn von Cenk Cakir ist ja jetzt auch, oder war auch Schiedsrichter. Ich weiß gar nicht, was mir jetzt mit ihm passiert ist. Der kam und dann haben sie gesagt, hier kommt ein Nachwuchsschiedsrichter. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob der jetzt noch Schiedsrichter ist oder nicht, weil ich habe nichts mehr gehört seit über einem Jahr. Jetzt. Es ist echt schwierig. Es ist traurig. Also ich bin ja selber Schiedsrichter gewesen. Ich bin ja selber zum Lehrgang gegangen hier in Deutschland. Und wenn ich das mal so vergleiche, dann kommst du dahin, hast so einen 3-Tage-Trip, wo du dann alles lernst und wo du dann dein Regelheftchen bekommst und so weiter und so fort und dann losgehst und machst und tust und ich glaube auch, dass innerhalb des Schiedsrichter-Daseins die Leute sehr, sehr gut zusammenhalten. Richtig. Also ich habe auch der Situation geschuldet einfach, dass die noch enger zusammenrücken. Aber wie gesagt, von außen, das jetzt attraktiv zu machen und wenn du jetzt fragst, was könnte man besser machen, kann ich nur sagen, die Gegebenheiten im Allgemeinen müssten sich schon erst mal ändern komplett. Das ist beim Fußball dieselbe Frage wie beim Schiedsrichter. Also wenn ich jetzt, wie kann man, keine Ahnung, den Verein besser machen, besser führen? Das ist genau wie beim Schiedsrichter. Es liegt, du musst vom Grunde an eigentlich alles erneuern. Du musst dein Mindset ändern. Und du musst sehr viel und was wir leider in Türkei einfach nicht haben, sehr viel Geduld haben. Und die ist einfach nicht da. Und wenn du keine Geduld hast, es gibt mal so ein Sprichwort, das hieß, ein Mann mit Zeit und Geduld könnte alles schaffen. Wir haben nichts von den dreien.
Das ist ein fürchterliches Fazit.
Ja, es ist leider, ich würde dir gern ein schöneres Fazit geben, aber es ist, wie gesagt, ich beobachte diesen Sport, also den Fußball seit 30 Jahren. Und ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich immer sagen wollte, jetzt wird es besser, jetzt wird es besser, jetzt wird es besser, jetzt wird es besser. Es wird immer schlimmer.
Du, wenn du dich mit Gala-Fans unterhältst, herzliche Grüße hier in meiner Nachbarschaft. Die haben einem auch im Sommer noch erzählt, dass Gala innerhalb der nächsten drei Jahre die Champions League gewinnt, so wie es ja auch der Plan ist mit den ganzen Investitionen und so. Und wenn man dann so leichte Skepsis äußert, so ein bisschen, weil man ja ein gebranntes Kind ist, wir haben das ja schon mehrmals erlebt, und dass es eben nie nachhaltig so war, dass es der türkische Fußball in die europäische Spitze reingeschafft hat, dann erntet man nur Unverständnis oder es wird einem Hass unterstellt. Aber das ist ja das Deprimierende. Also sportlich gesehen gibt es ja gerade wieder Dinge, die nach vorne gehen. Und auch was das Nationalteam angeht, natürlich in der Achterbahnfahrt, die dazu gehört, die aber jetzt auch nicht so untypisch ist für Nationalteams, aber was konnte man auch für positive Geschichten über eben den türkischen Fußball erzählen? Und leider kommen immer wieder solche Themen auch mit rein. Und dann springt natürlich so jemand wie ich auch drauf, immer auf die negativen Themen, was natürlich auch super ätzend ist, eigentlich für die komplette Liga und alle Fans.
Ja, aber was machst du denn, Max? Du machst doch nur deinen Job.
Ja, klar, glaube ich, mache ich auch nicht auch.
Da passiert was. Du sagst ja nicht, ich will jetzt auch dauerhaft, warte ich jetzt, bis die mal, die machen das schon selber. Also das verstehen wir Türken nicht anscheinend, immer sich schön in die Opferrolle stellen. Ihr wollt immer nur Schlechtes von uns. Nein, also wenn du sagst, wir hatten auch mal schöne und positive, ja, aber für mich ist das da oben eine komplette Achterbahn. Das ist, wenn das hier der riesen Eisberg ist, ganz da oben, da oben redest du nur. Da passieren manchmal gute Sachen. Alles da unter ist, solange das nicht gelöst wird, können wir zumindest nicht dauerhaft irgendwas erreichen. Die Gala hat vor 25 Jahren den UEFA Cup gewonnen. Danach waren sie ein Jahr später im Viertelfinale der Champions League und danach ging es nur noch bergab. Ich möchte sagen, ja, es war mal eine Situation da, die, was ich jetzt aber auch sagen muss, sich zu wiederholen scheint tatsächlich, weil so hat Gala damals auch angefangen. Und jetzt sind sie tatsächlich auf einem guten Weg. Ob das jetzt für irgendwas reicht, möchte ich jetzt nicht sagen. Aber auf jeden Fall ist das im Moment ein Hoch bei Gala, keine Frage, weil sie jetzt im Moment eine Projektmannschaft sind, ist einfach so. Aber es geht immer darum, es ist einfach nach oben zu kommen und es ist schwierig, oben zu bleiben. Und dieses Schwierig-oben-zu-bleiben, das habe ich bei den Türken noch nicht gesehen. Diese Kontinuität fehlt einfach.
Ja, ja gut. Und dann eben die Struktur. Also du kannst noch so gut als Einzelteam sein und vielleicht auch international mal was reißen, wenn du weiter Probleme hast, gute SchiedsrichterInnen zu finden, wenn du weiter in einem total überhitzten Umfeld, in dem Grautöne keine Rolle mehr spielen, versuchst irgendwas zu entwickeln. Also genau das, was du mit Zeit und Geduld gesagt hast. Ich glaube, dass das ein bisschen das Problem von ganz vielen Fußballliegen ist, weil es ist einfach so viel Emotion mit dabei und so viel Aufmerksamkeit drin. Und gerade die Journalistinnen und Journalisten brauchen ja auch jedes kleine Informationsding, dass man so eine Geschichte aufbauschen kann. Also so richtig geduldig ist da eigentlich keiner im Fußball. Aber dafür geht es da um zu viel Geld. Aber es wäre letztlich das, was man bräuchte und das, was man auch, wo ich auch mal dachte Anfang der 2000er, man wäre vielleicht genau da, weil da ja auch die Weiterentwicklung des Nationalteams und dann WM 2002 und so weiter und so fort, das schien so quasi aufeinander aufzubauen. Aber dann leider ging dann irgendwann, hat man dann gesehen, es war doch nur die Auffahrt zur Achterbahnabfahrt, die ist dann wieder abgefahren.
Ich kann ja genau erzählen, warum es wieder zur Abfahrt, was würde jetzt hier zu lang dauern einfach. Es gibt einfach Sachen, die in der Türkei niemand sieht. Wenn ich mit Deutschland dann mal nur als Beispiel, wenn ich da sehe, wer da den Verein leitet, welche Leute leiten den Verein, guck dir doch mal Bayern München an. Das sind alles ehemalige Spieler. Und nur als Beispiel, Bayern München ist für mich der bestgeführtesten Verein der Welt. Nur mal so das Nummer nebenbei. Und dann guck dir mal an bei Gala. Alles Geschäftsleute. Sorry, dass ich Gala sage, ich meine in der türkischen Liga. Aber auch Gala, alle. Also nur Geschäftsleute, die eben sich profilieren wollen. Sich profilieren wollen, weil sie haben Geld, aber sie sind nicht berühmt einfach. Und sie wollen sich darüber berühmt machen und zeigen. Wenn du Geld hast, aber du hast keine Macht über irgendwas, dann bringt sie das auch nicht. Bzw. für Leute, die das gerne brauchen. Es gibt natürlich Leute, die haben Geld und ziehen sich gerne zurück. Okay, aber wenn das nicht der Fall ist, dann brauchst du eine Plattform, eine Bühne. Und die benutzen diese Mannschaften als Bühne. Deswegen frage ich mich auch z.B., warum die sich nie richtig zusammengetan haben, um gegen sowas vorzugehen, weil sich jeder nur um sich selbst kümmert. Gala denkt jetzt, dass sie durch die Position, die sie jetzt haben, dem entfliegen können. Können sie aber nicht. Weil die Strukturen innerhalb des Fußballs, innerhalb des ganzen gesamten Fußballwesens mit den Schiedsrichtlern, in allem Drum und Dran, eben komplett neu aufgelebt werden muss und verändert werden muss. Solange sie sich da nicht zusammensitzen, zusammentun, kann niemand dem entgehen. Und das heißt, dann flüchtet einmal ganz kurz Gala und kommt dann wieder auf den Tatsachen des Bodenes zurück. Ganz klar. Also, das ist, das ist eine, sowas haben wir immer wieder erlebt. Sowas wird sich immer wieder holen.
Okay, dann habe ich noch eine letzte Frage. Was glaubst du kommt jetzt noch in diesen Skandal? War das jetzt schon die Spitze des Eisbergs? Wir nehmen ja quasi auf in der ständigen Angst vor der nächsten Pressemitteilung, die während dieser Sendung rauskommt. Oder glaubst du, wir haben jetzt das Schlimmste hinter uns?
Also, das werden, das habe ich ja gesagt am Anfang noch, Trainer und Funktionäre jetzt auch noch vernommen. Und allein wenn ich jetzt nur an einen Trainer denke, den Trainer vom Besiktas, Sergi Nyalcan, jeder wird jetzt wissen, was ich jetzt sagen möchte, also jeder der Türken, der ist ja bekannt für Wetten. Also der ist ja bekannt für Pferderennen. Der ist bekannt für ein ekstratisches Leben. Der hat, wenn ich das mal ganz kurz einwerfen kann, im Jahr 2003 hat er in dem Champions League Spiel gegen Chelsea auswärts auf sich selber getippt, dass er zwei Tore schießt. Das hat er auch gemacht. Also, und das war so offen. Also das war so offensichtlich und so. Und jetzt ist er Trainer und er ist jetzt auch aktiver Trainer. Und es werden ja Trainer auch aktive und auch nicht aktive werden jetzt praktisch durchleuchtet. Also klar werden die was bei ihm finden, weil wir wissen es ja auch alle. Wie geht man denn damit jetzt um? Also die Frage ist natürlich dann auch genau wann hat er jetzt immer gewettet? Wettet er dann? Okay, dann sagt er ja das Pferdewetten. Also hat er mit Fußball nichts zu tun und so weiter und so fort. Also da wird glaube ich noch was kommen. Also Funktionäre. Also ich glaube, wir haben also auf deine Fragen kann ich mal so sagen. Ich glaube, da kommt noch einiges auf uns zu. Weil wir haben jetzt, glaube ich, eher noch die unschuldigeren Leute durchleuchtet.
Okay.
Das ist meine Vermutung, ja. Und Funktionäre. Also ich glaube, wenn sie es richtig machen und richtig durchleuchten und alles, wenn die es so machen, wie sie es bei den Schiedsrichtern und bei den Spielern gemacht haben, dann glaube ich, kommt noch einiges auf uns zu. Und auch wir haben ja jetzt schon mit dem Präsidenten von Eibsball eine Gefängnisstrafe. Kannst du dir vorstellen, wo das auch noch hingehen kann alles. Also ich bin sehr gespannt, dass das wird. Auch diese Saison wird eine Saison, wo der Fußball bei weitem nicht in meinem Vordergrund steht. Ja, also für mich war, als das rauskam, war für mich die Saison eigentlich schon gelaufen. Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, wer Meister wird und so. Ist aber auch relativ wurscht. Wie weit kommt man in den Europa Cup? Ja, okay, das ist von Interesse natürlich auch allgemein für die nächste Jahr. Kommen wir zur WM nicht, auch Interesse. Aber das wird uns definitiv bis zum Saisonende und darüber hinaus noch begleiten, ziemlich sicher.
Gökhan, das spricht sehr dafür, dass ich mich nochmal bei dir melde. Bei den Funktionären, da habe ich schon so ein bisschen reinrecherchiert. Da gibt es ja, ich sag mal, schillernde Persönlichkeiten. Das ist ja wie in Deutschland in den 80ern, wo es eben auch so viele so Menschen, die zu Geld gekommen sind und die dann eben auch zu Ruhm kommen wollen und deswegen Präsident werden.
Deswegen, das sage ich ja, das sind keine Sportler. Das sind ja erst Recht, Geschäftsmänner. Und ich glaube, da kommt, also, der Ding kommt noch.
Gut, dann melde ich mich dann da bei dir. Für den Moment aber Gökhan Yagmur von transfermarkt.de. Vielen, vielen Dank, dass du mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk.
Sehr gerne. Vielen Dank auch.
Und ich danke natürlich auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern, denn ihr wisst ja, der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbe- und sponsorenfrei, unter anderem, weil wir mit Sportwetten nichts zu tun haben wollen. Deswegen ganz herzlichen Dank an alle da draußen, die diese Sendung hier auch möglich gemacht haben. Nämlich durch eure freiwillige Unterstützung. In der Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei mehrwerder im Rasenfunk. Ich hoffe, das war jetzt das richtige Thema, an dem du hier genannt wirst. HT bei Jan, bei KSC-Fans 2001, beim Stadionfahrer 1898. Herzliche Grüße und bei Härtelinho auf rasenfunk.de. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann, auch in der Videobeschreibung und in der Podcastbeschreibung. Jeder Betrag hilft und davon bekommen dann auch unsere Gäste ein kleines Honorar. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Unterstützung. Danke, dass ihr den Rasenfunk möglich macht. Unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de könnt ihr sehr gerne Feedback zu dieser Sendung hinterlassen. Und dann freue ich mich, euch bald hier wieder zu hören. Vielleicht ja in einer anderen Sendung. Macht's gut und bis dann. Ciao! Das war der Rasenfunk. Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser. Rasenfunk unterstützen ihr Knausa.